[Musique]
bonjour à tous aujourd'hui je vous parle
d'un nouveau produit qui va concerner
l'intérieur et la sécurité de votre
maison tout nouveau produit c'est la
caméra à 360 pour intérieur de bosch
smartphones on en a parlé il ya quelques
temps dans une précédente vidéo j'étais
rencontrer l'équipe de bochum art home
pas loin de l'arc de triomphe
si vous voulez aller voir la vidéo
d'ailleurs je vous invite à aller jeter
un petit coup d'oeil par ici comme ça
vous dire exactement quelle est la
solution globale de bosch marteau mais
là on va tester cette toute nouvelle
caméra à 360 degrés elle extrêmement
intéressant parce que pour faire de la
vidéo surveillance
elle vous permet effectivement filmer à
360 degrés de jour comme de nuit avec
des données qui sont sécurisées ça c'est
très très importants qui vont partir sur
le club de bosch directement en
allemagne
bosch a lancé il ya pas longtemps à
cette nouvelle solution pour la maison
connectée c'est une solution complète
tant pour la sécurisation de votre
domicile intérieur comme extérieur pour
le chauffage pour la régulation avec des
thermostats de radiateur avec des
connecteurs pour savoir si vos fenêtres
si vos pores sont ouvertes il ya
effectivement une système de sécurité
incendie également tout un univers
connectés au tour de la marque bosch
on va tout de suite commencer par une
boxing pour voir ce que ça dans le
ventre
voilà donc cette fameuse boîte pour la
caméra à 360 degrés pour l'intérieur
bosch smartphones alors on commence par
l'ouverture voire un petit peu ce cas
cette boîte dans le ventre on louvre
comme ça et hop nous voilà directement
sur la caméra qui est dissimulé ici
alors là très clairement bosch ne
l'expliquent télécharger et exécuter
l'application bosch smart caméras
montées la caméra il connecte
électricité scanner le qr 2
l'application à gauche marc caméra a
ajouté la caméra donc en fin de compte
votre caméra elle va s'ajouter
extrêmement rapidement on n'a qu'à la
prendre elle est extrêmement légère elle
est complètement escamotable la caméra
est là dedans donc on trouve à la
connecter elle sortira elle pivotera ici
et quand on voit la ferme et un petit
coup dessus et elle rentrera
c'est une caméra qui doit être tout le
temps connecté au secteur donc pas de
piles pas de batterie elle ne se
rechargent pas vous la branchez en
permanence à votre secteur elle a besoin
de deux choses
elle a besoin du secteur et à la dote
d'une connexion wifi ça ce sont les
adaptateurs
si vous êtes amené à aller à l'étranger
et sinon vous avez à l'intérieur un
manuel d'utilisation qui va vous
expliquer comment fonctionne cette
caméra qu'on voit effectivement ici des
capteurs qu'on peut retrouver de chaque
côté il y en a trois exactement ici un
micro haut parleurs qui vous permettra
d'écouter ce qui se passe dans votre
pièce mais également de pouvoir parler
le petit logo type boesch un produit qui
est très élégant très sympa et un
produit qui se mariera parfaitement bien
avec votre domicile la caméra ressemble
à ça vue de face on peut la faire
tourner sur le côté on voit derrière le
port pour brancher directement le
secteur le lecteur la carte sd et
dessous des patrons antidérapante et des
données techniques directement sur votre
caméra on va commencer par la brancher
et voir un petit peu ce que ça dit une
fois branché absolument rouge
normalement là elle est prête à
fonctionner
la caméra s'initialise et vient
directement ouvrir l'objectif
directement ici à la face de la caméra
c'est une caméra qui filme à 360° avec
une tête pivotante à 270 degrés elle
peut détecter des mouvements jusqu'à 8
mètres et normalement en termes de
sécurité
cet objet est tout simplement top
l'application est assez intuitive à
utiliser dès qu'il ya des mouvements
elle va filmer et elle va vous lui
notifier directement donc là si je mets
lecture on est en train de voir tout de
suite ce que la caméra est en train de
filmer directement c'est du direct avec
un léger différé
on peut voir l'état de la caméra on
active les notifications donc là on a le
nombre de notifications des mouvements
qui sont détectés par la caméra on peut
en ajouter certains à ses favoris on
paie de retrouver ici on peut les mettre
à la poubelle si on le souhaite et on a
accès à toutes nos informations c'est
vrai que c'est assez complet ce qui
ressort des premiers tests c'est que
cette caméra fonctionne plutôt bien
dès que je me déplace autour elle va
reconnaître les mouvements je te le voir
en direct sur mon application jeu peut
interagir je peux directement parlé via
l'interphone
je peux aussi bien après appelé la
police appelée un service de sécurité ça
fonctionne super bien
niveau qualité la caméra filme en 1080p
en full hd avec 30 images par seconde
alors c'est de la vidéosurveillance
n'est pas effectivement sur des
résolutions dingue mais du full hd ça
fonctionne quand même relativement bien
comme elle est à 360° la caméra fait du
tracking ce qui fait qu'on peut se
déplacer autour de la caméra dans une
pièce elle va suivre tous vos mouvements
et comme ça elle verra exactement ce que
vous êtes en train de faire alors de
toute façon c'est vraiment fait pour la
surveillance si vous êtes à domicile
vous la désactiver pas besoin de la
garder allumée par contre lorsque vous
n'êtes pas chez vous si jamais vous avez
un animal et bien ça va le traquer pour
voir un petit peu ce qui se passe dans
la maison quels sont les déplacements
vous pouvez régler la sensibilité pour
pas être embêté sur de fausses alertes
et ça c'est plutôt bien pensé autre
point positif la caméra filme dans noir
ce qui fait que en règle générale
lorsqu'on les parties on laisse pas les
lumières allumées donc votre caméra un
pouvoir filmer si vous avez des intrus
qui arrive directement dans le noir
comme ça au moins vous pourrez les
surprendre avant même qu'ils aient
repérer les caméras les vidéo vous
pouvez consulter directement sur votre
smartphone android ou ios
vous pouvez également les télécharger
en gros les vidéos vous pouvez récupérer
de trois manières différentes la
première je voulais dit elle sont
directement stockées sur la carte du 8
giga sur la micro sd sur la caméra
elles sont chiffrées donc pas de
problème de sécurité par rapport à ça
autre point intéressant elles sont
stockées pendant quinze jours jusqu'à
200 événements sur le club de bosch
directement en allemagne
et le troisième point vous pouvez les
télécharger directement dans votre
application pour pouvoir les consulter
ultérieurement
ce bel objet cette technologie à un prix
elle coûte exactement 249 euros et 95
centimes et comme je vous le disais elle
fonctionne merveilleusement bien tout
seul pour une caméra de surveillance ça
va mais dans l'absolu le mieux c'est de
pouvoir l'utiliser avec la solution
complète beau smartphone tout en sachant
qu'il ya différents kits vous avez les
starter kit avec quelques quelques
options vous allez pouvoir avoir ingéré
une option plus sécurité une option plus
chauffage vous pouvez carrément avoir le
full package mais en fonction de votre
maison en fonction de vos besoins en
fonction de votre appartement
ça ne va pas du tout coûte et le mépris
c'est vraiment une solution complète qui
est très très intéressante on voit
effectivement que les industriels se
penche de plus en plus dans la maison
connectée on y va très très rapidement
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire est ce que vous avez des
besoins en termes de sécurité ce que
vous envisagez d'acheter une caméra
intérieure pour la sécurisation
là où je tourne la vidéo on est au mois
de juillet on sait très bien que les
mois d'été sont des mois toujours un
petit peu plus compliqué en termes de
cambriolage est ce que une caméra comme
celle ci vous apporterez un gain de
sécurité pourrait vous rassurer est-ce
que cet objet pourrait vous aider et
vous être utile mais témoins tout en
commentaire merci d'avoir regardé la
vidéo si elle vous êtes lui je vous
invite à laisser un joli poussent vers
le haut et à vous abonner à la chaîne
mais quant à moi vous dis à très bientôt
pour de futurs vidéo
salut
non
[Musique]